[Music]
the ncbi gene database is a resource
that centralizes gene related
information into individual records
many different types of gene-specific
data are connected to the record
including sequence accessions
nomenclature genomic location and
organization
publications gene products and their
attributes expression
interactions pathways homology variation
and its phenotypic consequences and
useful
links to databases both internal and
external to ncbi
the content of gene is derived from both
automated data flows and curation by
ncbi staff the starting point is
typically the extraction of
gene-specific information from a
publicly available
annotated genome sequence the gene is
assigned a category for example
protein-coding rna
non-coding rna pseudogene ribosomal rna
or unknown based on the information
provided by each collaborating databases
the ncbi reference sequence database or
refsec database
is a comprehensive integrated
non-redundant
well annotated set of reference
sequences including genomic
transcript and protein similar to a
review article
a refseq is a synthesis of information
integrated across multiple sources at a
given time
refsects provide a foundation for
uniting sequence data with genetic and
functional information
they are generated to provide reference
standards for multiple purposes
ranging from genome annotation to
reporting locations of sequence
variation in medical records
the gene reference into function
database or gen rif database
is a short statement about the function
of a gene
gene rif's provide a simple mechanism
for allowing scientists
to add to the functional annotation of
genes described in the gene database
each gene rif has a pointer to the
pubmed id of a scientific publication
that provides evidence for the statement
made by the gene rif
the online mendelian inheritance in man
or omim
is a continuously updated catalog of
human genes and genetic disorders and
traits
with a particular focus on the gene
phenotype relationship
the following sections will help you
understand more about the ncbi gene
database
and how to navigate the database to
extract the information of your interest
the ncbi gene database is an important
resource
because it collects together in one
place information on each gene
and provides links to other ncbi and
related databases
this introduction includes a focus on
links to the pubmed database
access gene by using the drop down menu
from any of the ncbi interfaces
let's look at cftr the gene associated
with cystic fibrosis
at this moment there are nearly 3060
individual gene records referencing cftr
of which 353 come from humans
although these records are sorted by
relevance to the search term
to be certain you have the correct
genetic record search the database with
the official symbol for your gene
of these 96 records this first one is
the human gene
because this record is so large note the
table of contents on the right hand side
and the additional links to related
national library of medicine databases
and other genetic resources
this first summary section opens with
the official symbol
and the full name of the gene is defined
in the public database of the human
genome organizations
gene nomenclature committee however as
you can see from the also known as list
not everyone has used that official
symbol in their publications
this gene encodes a protein and the
summary includes information on how the
protein
functions and potential issues with gene
mutations
the refseq status is reviewed thus
in this gene record the cftr gene
sequence
is an annotated reference sequence
curated by ncbi staff
with unique identifiers and serving as a
baseline for medical
functional and comparative studies
genomic context describes where the gene
lives
in this case the gene is on chromosome 7
the q
or long arm in region 31.2
for information on how chromosomes are
mapped see the article by clair o'connor
the genome reference consortium
submitted the most recent assembly of
the human reference genome to genbank in
december of 2014
because new data and corrections have
changed cftr's location on the
chromosome
gene includes information on both the
current and past assembly to assist
researchers
note that the cftr gene starts after the
117.4 millionth base pair on chromosome
7 in this current assembly
this diagram shows the direction in
which the gene is red
remember the double helix can be read in
either direction
and convention states the chromosome be
presented with the shorter arm on the
top or to the left
cftr then is read toward the right but
this nearby cttnbp2 gene is red toward
the left or the shorter arm of the
chromosome
this next section provides a type of
gene browser that offers a tremendous
amount of information
click on the green line representing the
gene
now you can see information on the gene
in green information on the transcribed
messenger rna in blue
and information on the translated
protein in red
multiple blue and red lines represent
splice variants
variants which can generate different
messenger rnas
verified transcripts begin within while
variants beginning with x represent a
predicted mrna transcript or transcribed
protein
now let's jump to a specific location on
the gene and zoom in
note that the larger bars represent
exons and the smaller bars are introns
an important concept for researchers is
clinical variation
when variations in the gene have a
clinical significance
the darker the color the more pathogenic
or deadly the variation
notice that this particular variation
rs1800111
has a pubmed citation associated with it
additional information in the browser
includes the gene sequence
snps the single nucleotide polymorphisms
or how individuals differ from one
another and information on the axons and
introns
all with links to related databases this
next section
bibliography needs no introduction
these are selected pubmed citations
focusing on the human cftr gene
for citations on the similar genes and
other species homologs
click on this final link if you need
citations focusing on a specific
function of a gene
this section on generifs gene references
into function
can be very helpful a single sentence is
taken from the title or abstract that
concisely describes the function or
functions of the gene in that article
these links will take you into pubmed
just as pubmed citations can bring you
back into gene
there is a great deal of additional
information in the gene record which we
will cover in future videos
including phenotypes variation and
pathways interactions which link to
pubmed citations discussing those
interactions
protein information reference and
related sequences
and resource links i do want to
highlight the gene ontology section
which summarizes
and provides pubmed citations for the
functions processes and components known
for this gene
ontology is the study of what exists in
gene ontology
is the controlled vocabulary of terms
describing gene product characteristics
and is compiled in the gene ontology
annotation database
as you can see the gene database
provides a one-stop node to retrieve all
information related to the gene of
interest
if you scroll down to the mrna sequence
section you can also access the gene
sequence from the genbank database which
primarily store the dna and
mrna sequence information